how did one of the best-selling fantasy
authors of the 21st century Lucy
adaptation opportunity of a lifetime
just asked the kingkiller Chronicles
Patrick rothfuss fans of George R.R
Martin's fantasy series A Song of Ice
and Fire know just how torturous it is
to wait for a forthcoming book in a
series when there's no release date in
sight that said fans of The kingkiller
Chronicles series might want to have a
word with those desperate Martin readers
written by Patrick rothfuss the king
killer Chronicle hit shells in 2007 with
its first installment the Name of the
Wind Book 2 the wise man sphere followed
it up in 2011 after an extended but
reasonable delay however the third book
The Doors of Stone is still nowhere to
be found as of early 2023 readers have
been waiting for well over a decade for
the celebrated Saga to come to a close
with essentially no information about
when that conclusion will come in case
you're not one of the series to voted
fans the kingkiller chronicle is set in
the world of tamarans and told primarily
through the main characters oral history
as he recounts to a historian known as
chronicler the main character kavoth
might be a simple Innkeeper in the
story's present day but he wasn't
accomplished Wizard and musician known
by many ominous names in the past in the
Name of the Wind gavoth tells the story
of his tragic childhood and his time
spent in cities ravaged by crime
eventually arriving at a heralded
university where he begins to master a
variety of magical practices the wise
man's fear follows kavoth as his
education progresses and he travels to
further corners of the world in his
endless pursuit of the legendary demonic
group The chandrian between the over 1
million copies of the Name of the Wind
sold the wise man's fear reaching the
top spot on the New York Times
bestseller list and The Game of Thrones
driven fantasy craze of the mid-2010s
it's not all surprising that Hollywood
moved fairly quickly to get an
adaptation off the ground in the summer
of 2013 it was reported that a group of
writers and producers had options the
project but the rights expired after a
couple of years and Sir Hamilton's
scribe and Pulitzer Prize winner
lin-manuel Miranda as a self-proclaimed
Mega fan of rothfuss's work Miranda was
set to produce a TV series based on the
kingkiller chronicle this seemed to mean
only good things for Roth first as fresh
off the Mania aroused by Hamilton
Miranda was the hottest commodity in the
industry Miranda who was reportedly also
going to write original music for this
series was effusive with his praise for
the king killer Chronicle Books he told
vulture I think fans have good writing
just like the Name of the Wind I had not
read a lot of fantasy books at that
point but I read the first sentence and
I just I was very drawn in speaking to
Entertainment Weekly Miranda also said
his experience of bearing in HBO's as
dark materials helped him understand the
king killer Chronicle better
unfortunately the solution for how best
to approach the adaptation eluded even
Miranda's sharp mind and he left the
project in 2022 Roth versus being
elusive about the third book in The
Promise Trilogy for a while to the point
that many fans doubt the series will
ever reach a conclusion in fact his own
editor Betsy walheim wrote in a Facebook
post that she hasn't read a word of
rothfuss's work in years sowing more
seeds of doubt about the trajectory for
the book's release what's more as a
Reddit user summarized in summer 2022
rothfuss also raised money for his
charity by promising to release a new
chapter from The Doors of Stone by
February 2022 as of early 2023 the
chapter has yet to materialize and
rothfuss has yet to make any formal
announcements as to why which may do
some harm to his credibility in the eyes
of producers rothfuss has however
addressed his lack of punctuality a few
times you can't be more irritated about
not finishing this thing than me or my
publisher you got it at best your third
in line it's worth noting that rothfuss
pretty much entered the sci-fi fantasy
scene with the name of the wind and he
probably didn't expect his first two
books to blow up as much as he did
unlike authors like George R.R Martin
who has been writing consistently for
decades rothfuss doesn't have the
long-standing reputation that might
pacify fans regarding Long delays in his
writing it's also worth acknowledging
that rothfuss has released two King
killer novellas in the time since the
wise man's fear came out so fans can
rest assured the universe has not been
sitting stagnantly since the release of
book two it's likely that after Game of
Thrones outstripped its source material
Hollywood might be more liable to look
afghan's unfinished series Miranda's
departure may not Mark the end of the
road for the king killer Chronicles
Hollywood Journey but it may be the end
until the author processes a concluding
installment
[Music]